c sharp a statically typed general
purpose programming language famous for
being the workhorse of the windows.net
framework it was created in the year
2000 by anders heilsberg at microsoft it
was designed as a modern c-like
object-oriented language and was
originally going to be called cool
initially it was criticized as imitation
java but it's evolved into one of the
most popular and well-loved languages to
this day it can be used to build almost
anything like desktop apps on.net core
cross-platform mobile apps with xamarin
web applications with blazer and video
games with the unity framework it became
open source software in 2014 and can be
used to build apps outside of the
dot-net framework c-sharp code is
compiled into an intermediate language
which can then be interpreted by the
common language runtime where it can be
executed as native machine code on any
operating system without the need to
recompile it's known primarily as an
object oriented language but also
supports functional lambda expressions
and has the ability to write a
declarative query on any data structure
with a feature called link it's a memory
safe language thanks to garbage
collection although it is possible to
create an unsafe context if you want to
allocate your own memory with pointers
to get started install the.net core sdk
then open the terminal to an empty
directory and run.net new to create a
new application that creates a
program.cs file that imports the system
namespace at the top then provides a
class with a main function which is
where your code will start executing
declare a variable by starting with a
type followed by a name and value by
default a value cannot be null but you
can make it nullable by adding a
question mark to the type now to
organize our code and share it in other
files we will wrap it in a namespace we
can then create a new class inside the
namespace that has a constructor when
the class is instantiated and a
destructor when the class goes out of
scope classes support inheritance
polymorphism and everything else you
would expect in a modern object-oriented
language we can define a property on the
class and make it readable with get or
writable with set the language doesn't
have top level functions but rather
methods that are defined as a member of
a class however it does support lambda
expressions or anonymous functions and
other functional programming patterns
when it comes to asynchronous
programming it supports a task-based
asynchronous pattern allowing you to
write non-blocking code using the async
await syntax now to compile and execute
your code use the.net run command this
has been c sharp in 100 seconds hit the
like button and subscribe if you want to
see more short videos like this and let
me know in the comments if you want to
see a full.net or unity tutorial thanks
for watching and i will see you in the
next one